[Music]
hello and welcome everyone good morning
good afternoon good evening wherever you
are tuning in from
we're so excited for you to join us
today my name is jessica chung i'm an
admissions officer
at the stanford graduate school of
business we're super excited to
share a little bit about life at the gsb
and beyond with you all today so here's
what's
what today's event is going to include
i'm going to give a brief introduction
to our global community
and then i'm going to introduce our
panelists or rather our panelists are
going to introduce themselves
we're going to have a couple of prepared
questions to get warmed up and then
finally
we're going to spend most of our time
looking at your questions so again
please use that q a box
and you can also upvote any questions
that other attendees have submitted
that you would like to know the answers
to all together we're going to spend
about 55 minutes together
and hopefully we're going to get as many
of your
questions answered as possible
so first to give a little bit of an
overview of our community as i mentioned
we have a truly global community on our
campus
for example the class of 2021 that is
graduating this year
includes 43 international students we
have 66 countries
represented in that community and 70
languages spoken
in that class of 2021.
in addition our community includes many
different clubs and organizations
supporting the
incredible diversity of our community
clubs like the africa business club the
asian business student association
the business in india club the greater
china business club
the student association international
committee
we have many many different ways that
students can get involved and that
students can
support one another and have an impact
on our community
and beyond really excited to be joined
by
a number of panelists including current
students and alumni
my apologies to vincent um let me see if
i can
okay i wonder if i can fix this but
um why don't julia if you could go ahead
and get us started and introduce
yourself
and tell us where you're from and
um and a little bit about what brought
you to the gsb
sure thing um hi everyone i'm julia i'm
originally from seoul south korea
um but i grew up i'm moving between
korea and america so i went to college
in duke
um i decided to come to the gsb and i
just pursue an mba degree mainly because
i wanted to seek um two things one
a career pivot and two a network of
i guess individuals who are passionate
about making
a difference in the world and there
certainly has been a lot of both um
in the past year alone i think i'm the
only current student on the panel today
and very excited to be here
awesome thank you
leo hi how are you
hey nice to meet you all um i'm leo i
used to be a military man before i
joined the gsb
um used to be a lieutenant in the korean
air force
uh grew up in uh seoul the whole time
and all
to all my schools here before the gst um
after two years there i started working
as an investment banker in new york and
right now i'm back in korea working
private equity
uh yep uh happy to talk about
transitioning from
non-traditional backgrounds to the
post-mba careers that look
more traditional plus adjusting to
uh first time ever studies in new york
in stanford in the u.s
awesome thank you
rich do you want to speak next
sure hey guys rich here i'm originally
from the philippines i went to the gsp
class of 2020. prior to that i was doing
a mix of
education and finance i did invest in
banking equity research for about five
six years
i was also a part-time university
lecturer then i went to the gsp and now
i run an edtech and tech startup
uh based in singapore uh with operations
in the philippines and indonesia
it's called nice to meet you all
awesome thank you saswadi
hey hi everybody i'm shashvati you can
call me sash
i uh spent most of my time uh
pre-gsp working at unilever so i worked
in the cpg industry in india
uh pivoted to uh venture investing post
the gsp uh i have been running for the
past
year have been running a venture studio
in india called meraki labs
uh yeah happy to chat about uh career
pivots
and you know how you think about uh just
careers outside the u.s
happy to talk about that awesome thank
you
finally vincent everyone um
my name is vince joining everyone from
palo alto
5am here but very very happy to be here
i
graduated with sash and rich in the
class of 2020.
prior to business school i was at bain
and company
and i rejoined my firm but transferred
from the from the singapore to the san
francisco office so
i guess the perspective i can offer is
not a career pivot
but you know staying within your
industry but transferring countries
awesome thank you and thank you so much
for joining us at 5 a.m i know that it's
kind of a brutal hour but
we're really grateful to have all of you
here
um so i'll begin with a question that i
think
julia spoke to a little bit already but
i'm curious about
why why an mba and especially why a
stanford
mba so what what was it that made you
decide to
pursue another degree rather than
continuing to
to work and what was it about stanford
in particular
yeah so i think uh for me it's sort of
similar to what julia said
uh as well uh i was uh i had worked for
five years
in cpg in india and i sort of was
looking at
uh exploring something in the startup
ecosystem in india
uh so uh some questions that were
already in my mind is what sort of rules
what sort of
domains etc and something that i um
i felt that i was ill-equipped in terms
of skills in terms of my mindset
et cetera that um i needed uh
guidance and i needed something that
would sort of augment
uh my skills in a way so i decided to
take the plunge and take a break in my
career
so that i could get that time to sort of
figure out what i want to do next
and uh gst was a good uh
filler in that sense that it it gave me
obviously
uh got to meet a bunch of people got a
lot
more context and helped me think through
my career decisions
specifically by gsb i think uh
i think i've always had this fascination
that i definitely wanted to
go to the us study abroad and have
an mba from abroad i think what appeal
from
for specifically for the gsp was its
strong uh i would say geographical
location and
not just from the good weather
perspective but also the fact that it's
in the
area and obviously heavily influenced by
the entrepreneurial
culture so given that that's where i was
leaning towards it made a logical choice
awesome thank you for sharing that
anybody else want to chime in about why
an mba
and why stanford
i can go um so for me
i didn't really get the chance to study
overseas
and it it it was always really part of
my bucket list
to you know take it take a degree abroad
and so like broadly that's what the ymba
you know it's not like you know the very
complex reason that people
expect but that was my main reason
and then ygsb i chose it versus the
other programs i got into because it
really focused on soft skills
coming from management consulting i
really wasn't looking for you know
the content of business school per se i
wasn't looking to
learn financial modeling and whatnot
because i had really i had already had
experience in that
and so i wanted a school that emphasized
things like leadership things like being
vulnerable and actually
um you know teach you how to potentially
fire an employee like that's probably
not a best example but we
um or teach you how to have a feedback
conversation with a supervisee
and the gsb's pedagogy and emphasis on
role plays and whatnot
allowed for that unique experience
relative to the other programs
absolutely thank you for sharing that um
so i'm also curious about
sort of the obviously this this event is
all about your journey from
wherever you're from to the gsb um
how did you i guess was there anything
that surprised you about the gsb was
there and were there any like rumors or
myths
that you had heard about the gsb prior
to
arriving and then in what ways did your
experience sort of dispel
those myths
or anything that surprised you about
your experience
and give it a go so so prior to entering
the gsb
and you know if you look at sort of just
business school forums and all these
statistics right
so in your head you you sort of overplay
the gst as
a place where these brilliant amazing
people
you know all a bunch of together in a
single singular place and so
for me coming into the gsb i was
pretty overwhelmed with how much i had
to sort of step
up just to sort of fit in the community
of a lot of overachievers and when i got
to the gsp
what really surprised me what stood out
to me was just how welcoming everyone is
how an intimidating environment is how
how friendly it is and
you know it's actually a very very safe
space to just be yourself and
i think allowing myself to just
and have a great time without having to
like put up a face i think that was i
think a very very pleasant surprise
during my
two years there awesome thank you
i think for me um there are two things i
think the first
is that um the gsb has a reputation for
i guess really encouraging startups and
entrepreneurship
and that has been very true and i think
that was almost surprising to the extent
of which it was true and especially
as a current student i can attest that
so many of my conversations
involve me like brainstorming with my
friends on different startup ideas that
we should be pursuing
um but i guess on the flip side of that
there is still a significant number of
classmates who are interested in
traditional industries like consulting
or banking
and i think that is kind of a myth that
the gsb does have that
um that students who come here only
pursuing let's say a vc or
entrepreneurship because i don't think
that's the case i think there are
definitely
a healthy number of people who are
pursuing more professional career treks
and
i think because there are a lot of
students who come into the program with
previous
experience in those fields it's made for
a very fostering environment
for people who are interested in going
towards those industries
kind of piggybacking on that my two
cents
on that aspect of the traditional
industry
in stanford i think is yes one i was
also surprised at how everybody really
is
worshiping early stage and venture
capital and startups but
also stanford is actually well we're not
known for for example a finance school
but in terms of the entry cl
and entrance profile of the people
coming in it is the school that has the
highest percentage
of students who've been in private
equity or consulting
for example so when i was preparing to
actually go to one of those industries
my classmates are really helpful and for
people who are
pivoting from non-traditional industries
to those that are
traditional i think the class profile
actually helps out
in many ways and to me also what also
surprised me
uh when i first entered was uh i think
this was also mentioned
but how comfortable the setting was
how inclusive it was in mingling with
people
who are the most overachieving
individuals in their
each sector i mean one day i went i went
the
day that i went to my first class i sat
next to a
classmate named jessica um i
said hey what did you do before the gsp
she said i used to be an athlete
i used to uh i used to do something with
water polo
and i said hey i'm from the military i
haven't taken any accounting or finance
i know nothing about business we're kind
of similar
i go home i look her up on the internet
and found out
she has four golden medals from the
olympics
and i dare said that we're similar
this seating of 400 people
from each of their industries who've
definitely over achieved and you're
sitting sitting
outside them right next to them in
classes
discussing problems sharing ideas and
then one day you
find out you are one of them and i think
i remember
one really big lesson from the first day
of gsb
when derek bolton uh in cemex
in a huge auditorium would say uh one
thing i want to tell you for the last
time
and first time is that we do not make
mistakes
and at that time i thought oh maybe i'm
a mistake but
i think everybody's thinking the same
thing when these overachievers are
getting together from
across the globe and actually we're
learning a ton from each other
and the setting for that uh stanford
does an amazing job at it awesome thank
you for that
and i will say that you know as an
admissions officer it's really true
we're perfect we make no mistakes
um so i mean i think we're we're very
i think we're very grateful for the
community that we get to build as well
and see you all
thriving yeah we feel very grateful
um i'm also wondering
um i guess what were
what were some of the most uh
transformative
or meaningful or helpful experiences
that you had on campus whether that's
being a part of
a particular community or certain
resources or opportunities what were
some of the things that were most
transformative meaningful or helpful
in your experience
i can chime in um i think
what i i think career-wise what i got
motion to gsb
apart from you know a great network of
people is actually the career coaching
that the career center
gave me so despite
going back to management consulting at
the gsb
i was able to explore professional
passions i didn't know i had
um and just these passions are like
considered i bet
i guess a bit more non-conventional
because
after consulting i intend to exit to
either two industries
one is video games and two is theme
parks
and um it was the career coaches at the
gsb that brought those things out of me
i actually only recruited for video game
companies
for my summer internship and that's
where i discovered that hey like this is
something i really want to do
once i finish my consulting sponsorship
theme parks wasn't an option for visa
reasons but soon it will be
and so i'm excited for that and i would
not have arrived at that conclusion
without
the gsb's career office also
one thing to plug is that my significant
other is still
an mba so we've been together seven
years and my boyfriend
um just i just co-hosted
a theme parks brown bag lunch with my
boyfriend with like some executives from
universal studios
you know like i guess it's one way to
say that the gsb
community still sticks with you after
business school and after graduating
i can go next uh so i think for me one
of the
most memorable experiences at the gsb
was
leading a global study trip to india uh
so this
is uh just for context it's basically a
trip that about 20 to 30 mba ones
go on and it's led the trip is led by
four to five
mba twos so uh me and four of
my classmates we put this entire trip
together
and it was it was memorable for a couple
of reasons one
it was an opportunity to show people who
have never visited india what
your business in india looks like what
are challenges
just getting to understand more from a
roots level
and i think the other thing was you just
get to meet another set of 30 amazing
folks
who you might not have crossed paths
with otherwise
so um yeah i think those seven days were
some of the best uh discussions i've had
some of the best
experiences we've had together both
professionally as well as a cultural
experiences so yeah so i i think the
highlight for me
was that one trip that i uh
i can go um my favorite experience so
far
only halfway through i can't believe
it's going by so quickly
uh what's the lean launch pad class um i
i don't think i had the courage to i
guess pursue an idea by myself without
the structured curriculum and so
i guess that opportunity to do an
action learning class as
stereotypical as it sounds was really
valuable and opening my eyes to
how much fun i could have working on a
startup from ground zero and so would
highly recommend
any and all of you to try it out um if
you get to come to the gsp
and even if you don't think that startup
is a path that you're
potentially interested in pursuing on
the long term
i also have an experience that i do wish
that any and all of you
really really tries out it's called the
gsb
show it's student-led musical
uh that over 150 to 200 people
participate every year
it's actually more attended than the
graduation ceremony
so you see how important it is uh
students and
professors and significant others and
sometimes just other members of the
campus to participate to create a
musical comedy
around uh i think it was around two
hours and we actually rent
out a theater to put the show on
and the writers who are also students
would put
all the existing inside jokes of that
year into that show
and singers will be students dancers
will be students etc and
to me i i was the dance director for the
show of 2017 and 2018
and uh it was an unforgettable
experience
um having 100 to 200 people and dance
together
and you know what's interesting about
this show is that
uh you know i know all of you have your
talents too
that are not career related and that
could be put on a stage
people know that this is one of their
last chances to really fire it up
and and the level of passion that comes
from that
uh opportunistic mindset is is
is incredible you can look up the show
online and
if you look up business school shows
you'll see
other foleys from our competitive
institutions on the east coast etc and
one way to gauge which school is the
right fit for you is to find out which
one's the most funny and interesting
great advice so you might not have any
gold medals but you can dance is what i
is what i'm hearing so far
awesome thank you all for that um
so i'm going to turn now to our q a box
and to our attendees thank you for
submitting some really really thoughtful
questions and please continue to
submit your questions and upvote
questions that you're interested in
hearing the answers to
i'm going to sort of combine and
rephrase some of these questions because
i think there are some overlapping
themes
some of our attendees are wondering what
sort of going back in time what are some
tips that you
have um so what perhaps what advice
would you give to yourself as an
applicant and what tips do you have for
future applicants
such as our attendees here
i can take it then everyone can build on
it
i guess uh i think
i i think i think i would i would say so
obviously admissions is a black box and
maybe you will ingest the cooking
can shed some light into that like i
don't know why i got in
but i think this is a bit
like my genuine advice is just to be
authentic in your application
right like the essay question is i'm not
sure if it's still the same but it's
what matters most to you and why
and some people tend to over engineer
their answers or some people think that
there is a standard answer that will get
you accepted
the reality is there is not and there's
probably one answer like one a different
answer for every single person here
um and so i think that
what got me in was being true to myself
and authenticity and like just writing
what i felt like writing about
um one thing i heard prior to applying
was your essay as
he has to ooze passion right and i was
lucky enough that i was
passionate about passionate enough about
gay rights in southeast asia and so i
wrote about that and
i knew that was and i guess it was a
passionate reason to get in and so that
was
my thing
just to add to vince is a little bit i
guess for me it's
not to never forget that there are two
parts to that essay
question it's sort of the what and the
why
and i think being able to like flesh out
both i think is pretty important
and most people do forget the latter
part and how to dig deep into like
your core and actually try to find out
you know what what what makes you be who
you are and i think that's really
important to like
go through that process
yeah absolutely um i think both of those
pieces of advice are really really apt
i know i'm the the admissions specialist
on the panel but
um both of those i think both pieces of
advice are really really apt
um i think it's so important to
reflect before starting the application
or before submitting your application it
is really
about authenticity about
sharing what drives you so we're
interested not just in what you've
accomplished but also like what has
driven you
what has motivated those accomplishments
what are you passionate about so i think
vince your your advice is really really
apt and i often hear from students that
sort of the first step in the
application process is taking that step
back
and really reflecting on what matters to
you most and why
um what do you want to use this
opportunity for
and and then sort of using the
application as a
as a tool to drive reflection um and
rich i think your advice is also really
really accurate
um to dig past the surface level
as you're responding to our questions
and as you're writing the application um
we're interested not just
in what you've accomplished but how have
you accomplished it
how have you led people how have you
exhibited strategic thinking how have
you seen beyond what's in front of you
how have you performed beyond what
what's expected of you
how have you mobilized and influenced
other people how have you gotten other
people to support your ideas and your
solutions
how have you supported other people and
how have you cultivated
a team or mentored others those are all
the things that we're interested in or
many of the things that we're interested
in
so we're interested not just in what
you've accomplished but how you've
accomplished it
how you've demonstrated leadership how
you've had an impact
and then i think of course we're
interested not just in what matters to
you but why does it matter to you so
i think as much as you can think about
um
everything a step deeper um i think that
will benefit you in the
application process so there's a great
question and great answers from our
panelists as well
there's a great question from mini
about your experiences at the gsb and
mini asks how did you expand your
network
and experience in your respective
industries while you were at the gsb
and what resources did you find most
useful
through the program
um so i think uh i'll answer from the
perspective of
somebody who's changed industries
so i think some of the uh
best resources that you have on campus
in terms of
you know developing a context about
industries or sort of
building those relationships with people
in the industry is through the many
industrial clubs that we have at
stanford
all the clubs are most of the clubs are
student-run
and these are folks who have either
worked in that industry or are
themselves switching into that industry
so it gives you a lot of perspective
the club obviously becomes a microcosm
of people who are interested in similar
activities similar
uh sort of ideas that maybe you might be
interested in
ah so yeah so i would say that's one
very
good resource that you should definitely
check out
at the gsp
yeah just to add upon that totally echo
and the sentiments around your
classmates and the gsb network being the
most
valuable primary source of expanding
your network and then i would say
the faculty here both the professors and
the lecturers alike
are extremely well connected and
you know we would just be like oh i like
to talk to someone in this industry and
they're like oh i know the ceo of this
company and that company
and they would just connect you and it's
just magical what um
the gsb network can i guess open doors
to
and i'd also say a lot of my friends
here have
also had success with cold emails
because i think a lot of people are
genuinely interested in speaking to gsb
students um
who have something interesting to say
about the industry that they're in
and so i've also had success um reaching
out to you know both alumni and people
who have
no immediate connection to the gsb and
getting them to
agree to a quick 20 minute call and so i
think it's all about
how intentional and proactive you are
about being i guess
you know i guess uh exchanging value
in your networking
i want to give an example to both those
points on the email address
and the power of the network um as i
mentioned a while ago i was interested
in video games which is
you know not a not a very conventional
industry to exit to
um it was and for one like
i when i was in my second year i was
president of the video game club
uh while president of the video game
club we did the first
inaugural um video game
career trek at the gsb
and surprisingly enough like with the
stanford email address
maybe 80 of the companies we reached out
to
actually replied within like a few days
and volunteered themselves
as stops for this video game career
track so we were able to visit cool
companies like roblox
twitch ea games there was even a
video game vc fund um that came to
campus to present
and so i guess that's a testament to the
power of the email address second
is again on video games um
the network internally is really strong
um a couple of my classmates were part
of the video game industry prior to
entering so that made
networking with the larger companies
easier
and also there's just people pursuing
the same interests as you
um there were five of us who were
members of the
executive team at the video game club
and you know one of them one of them
like
records piano music on spotify and has
millions of views
just just like playing video game piano
music on spotify
and so like that's just an interesting
narrative and you know a proof point for
like
just the varying range of interests
across the gsp
i think uh we can put it this way where
whatever your short-term goal is there's
somebody in the classroom who's done it
been there done that and there's also
somebody else in the classroom who has
the same goal as you
and then there's somebody in the alumni
network and outside of the alumni
network who are waiting for you
really hands open arms open to help out
as needed because they have received
that help and they want to pay for it
too
so there's just you're surrounded by
people who will push you and
pull you and accompany you through
whatever journey you're trying to take
so
i think resources and networking
connections was the last thing i had to
worry about when i was
in stanford i think i worry more about
it after i graduated
and just to close the loop on this like
two things right one i think
is your network does extend even beyond
the us like i personally wanted to go
back to asia all the time and i think
that
that gsb name does carry over across
borders
and i do think your problem not isn't
about how to network
it's about focusing your met your where
you network
because you only have two years of the
gsb so it's really more about like
knowing who you want to talk to where
you want to be
and just going for that
awesome thank you all so much for
sharing
and we have a couple questions too about
sort of pivoting and i love how all of
your answers sort of touched on how
how you can really leverage the
community to to
to pivot industries if that if that's
what you want to do
um so there are a couple questions about
pivoting industries
um so if any of you have anything you
want to add about
career pivots please feel free to chime
in there is one
question in particular for
[Music]
one question in particular for leo about
coming from sort of a non-traditional
military background so if you could shed
some light on
that transition um
i think uh that would be really really
awesome and then if anybody else wants
to chime in about
um pivoting that would be
that would be really welcome as as well
sure i'd love to share um let me try to
go as briefly as possible it's a long
story
how why i wanted to and how it happened
so i come from an untraditional
background in that
it was a military plus that i majored in
french literature in undergrad and never
took a course in business accounting or
finance or whatever
i originally wanted to work for a
non-profit organization
i interned at unesco in paris and
working
on things like art preservation language
preservations those things were
my thing uh back when i was in college
and then
um in 2012 when i was an intern there
due to some political circumstances
united states
and some other countries stopped funding
the organization
and all the budgets for the little small
beautiful projects that i love started
getting cut
and that's when i first thought ooh
money is important
well put in another way it would be
great if i could be working in
a role where i get to impact
the flow of funds going to people or
organizations or businesses that matter
is my normal interview answer but then i
went to the military i was spending
three and a half years there as a
full-time officer because
uh it's one of the things when korean
men do when
they don't know what to do with their
career um
during my third second to third year i
found out that there are industries
called investment banking or private
equity
or also maybe management consulting
which are all traditional post mba
careers
that may get me closer to my goals and
started preparing
when i first came to school i found out
that
all my classmates have already done
investment banking and private equity
and they were my core resources in
preparing
and one thing people misunderstand about
stanford
campus is that not a lot of people end
up going to banking
it's not because people are not
interested in finance or
people are less trained in finance it's
just that they've already done it before
and i i did i think around 30 to 40 mock
interviews with
my classmates in my section and served
them for a korean food night
soju night and then we were all good on
that
i had i did have to network uh flying
from the east and west coast
during thanksgiving etc to meet
uh the recruiters both racket banks at
that time
to actually get into the process and
ended up interviewing with all the
companies uh got an offer
in san francisco and new york i thought
it would be great to
start a finance career in new york and
then i did have to come back to korea
because i went to stanford on a
fulbright scholarship which requires two
years of
home country residency um throughout
all that process i think for every
single
pivot or every single way to the next
step
uh stanford community was the core in
facilitating
um because i started my career in bank
of america after gsb
and that was through campus recruiting
when i moved from bank of america to
uh cross-border private equity in korea
it was
also through introductions in the
stanford alumni network and once i had a
trip
to hong kong meeting 10 to 15 private
equity companies that i thought would be
worth discussing with and they were
all every single one of them were bosses
of my former bosses of my classmates
so i think uh all these structured
recruiting processes
for consulting or banking or
the more traditional post nba careers
are
well structured enough in a way that if
you go to school and
prepare and have your friends help out
uh it works out
because these traditional mba mba
careers are
traditional call so-called traditional
because they take
people who pivot
just to add to that i think mine was
probably an example of
something that was very unstructured so
for so typically uh early stage
investing
is based on networking so whether you're
looking
uh to transition into a state investing
in the us
or anywhere across the world uh it's
it's a very network
driven industry to begin with so i think
that's where i
sort of echo what uh leo was just
mentioning that the
strength of the community within the gsb
and the alumni
really really helps
just interacting with a lot of the
classmates who had spent a lot of time
in pcs
who had spent a lot of time investing
just to understand you know how they
do it just picking their brain and just
getting a lot like the and the best part
is people are always happy to help you
and you know you will never feel like
uh you'll never you should never
hesitate for help they're always always
super helpful to
sort of just sit down with you and
explain you certain things if you
are very unfamiliar with it so
definitely uh
i think uh got a lot of help in terms of
you know identifying who i should
talk to uh for me i was very clear that
i was definitely coming back to india
uh right after graduation and uh
with that perspective you know even
during my summers when i was trying to
figure out where how do i break into the
bc ecosystem in india i got a bunch of
leads
got um really good advice on how to sort
of make that transition
how to think how to uh sort of carry
myself in that career
so yeah completely i for that you know
people are the strength of the gsp
and you leverage you can really leverage
them as
much as you can
so thank you both for those insights
there are a couple questions
about classes at the gsb
some folks are wondering what were some
of the your favorite or
most memorable classes there's one
question for julia in particular about
entrepreneurship classes so maybe julia
if you can start there
and then if anybody else has any
experiences with classes that they'd
like to share
please feel free to chime in after
definitely um yeah in addition to lean
launchpad there's so many different
startup classes here at the gsb it seems
like new ones are popping up left and
right and
there's the startup garage which is
obviously also very famous and then
there's launch pad at the design school
there's climate ventures programs and
there's
designing for extreme affordability and
there's so many different types of
entrepreneurship classes that you can
take and so
i guess in addition to classes that help
you i guess incubate your own idea
i also enjoy taking formation of impact
ventures because
um social ventures is also a space that
interests me a lot and
it's basically like a case study class
where you go through
let's say a dozen or so social ventures
over the course of the quarter
um and so yeah i would say it really
depends on what type of knowledge you're
seeking but there has been
a variety of courses that i'm i've been
able to take even as an mba one
i would just close out with saying that
i think the learning also comes from
outside of the classroom and so it's not
just about the course that you're taking
but again
as so many of your classmates have so
much experience and anything and
everything that you could have questions
about
and so just having that really great
advisory board
living on campus with you has been
really helpful
awesome thank you any other favorite
classes that
people are reflecting on
i like strategic communication
and winning writing these are i think
two of my favorite comp space classes
which i think helps really sharpen like
let's say the more intangibles because
of yourself uh in the first class
it's you basically you have to give a uh
a speech in front of class i think it's
once a week and then you watch a video
of yourself and then
you critique yourself uh not
not as not very fun but it i think it is
very very
very helpful in seeing how you come
across to other people and i think
that's something
you know jsp is a very very safe space
to practice these skills and i think
that's
it's really a fantastic platform
i mentioned something a while ago on the
emphasis on soft skills i want to give
examples of that
one of the most impactful classes i took
at the gsb was
touchy feely or formerly known as
interpersonal dynamics
which is basically like the setup is we
were trapped in a room for like forget
four hours
once a week with 11 other people
and all we d all we did were exercises
in which we just gave very straight-up
feedback to each other
and there was emphasis on you know being
vulnerable and authentic
and just being honest with people and in
that setting i was able to communicate
really
you know things i would be uncomfortable
communicating
outside of that context outside of that
safe space
um touching on topics such as race
such as um you know
how one like
how how i how like how how some person
phrased the sentence
was a bit offensive so some other people
like witnessing that and like seeing my
blind spots like that was really
impactful to me and i think
the language and the parlance that that
um
course taught me like are lessons that i
still
bring and i still like use to this day
even in the professional context
especially when you're like
you know having your feedback chat with
your supervisee
at work like super impactful other
classes you can look at
are leadership labs and art of
self-coaching
those two other classes were also super
impactful i won't go into detail but
they're worth looking up really good
classes that are structured around
um paired coaching and um
role playing you get a lot from those
awesome thank you i think you um
actually answered one of the other
questions in the q a box about soft
skills and how
the gsb experience cultivates some of
those soft skills
there's another great question in the q
a box about
leadership so yukiho asks
um how did your leadership change during
the two years at stanford
um in what way and and how
um so vince you mentioned some of the
classes i'm curious for
for other folks how how did your
leadership change
and how did that happen
so to be very honest i wouldn't say that
it's like a
it's like a step jump that you can see
you're at zero one day and you're at one
i think it's a continuous journey
and the point that vince mentioned about
these classes is
that it makes you a lot more self-aware
so it's it's like i can't say that i
am implementing uh everything that i
learned from touchy feely very well but
yes i know that i'm doing much better
than i was probably doing two years back
so
um so yeah there are many things so
that's just one thing i would
sort of caveat the entire answer with
that
you shouldn't think of it like oh these
two years after these two years you'll
be able to actually
do something very drastically different
but what these
courses do is they give you interesting
mental models to think about yourself
be aware of what you're doing what
you're saying how you are behaving with
people
and it just helps you set that context
for really becoming a good leader in the
future
but yeah that's my new sense on this
thanks for that insight that's helpful
um so there's a number of questions
about life
after the gsb as well and
i think a few folks are wondering both
about
sort of the opportunities within the u.s
so perhaps vince you can speak to that
and
other folks are wondering about sort of
transitioning back to
their home country afterwards so what
were your experiences with that
transition
to life after the gsb uh whether you
were looking to return to your home
country or to stay in the u.s
so i could take the staying at the u.s
i might not be able to directly answer
it because
the thing about my scenario was i was
pre-committed
to transfer from the singapore to the
san francisco office even before
starting at the gsb granted
um i think one thing i'd like to point
out
is that for international students the
mba degree at the gsb
has now been accredited as a stem degree
which means that
if you want to stay you are guaranteed
that you can
you're able to work here um for at least
three years post graduation and
in general if you're with you know a
credible company
within those three years um
you should be able to either win a
lottery a
visa lottery that allows you to stay
indefinitely
or you know you could kick start or
finish a green card
process within that time frame and so
like that's one of the things that makes
the transition easier
and also i think one thing i realized
was
the gsb has a disproportionate
representation of people that
stay in one geography after graduation
i think that 50 to 60 percent of
my classmates are still in the bay area
working in various industries and that
just
and as someone who literally like packed
his bags to move here and didn't know
anyone
it's great that the network i actually
built while
i was at the gsb is still within
physical reach
i guess for covid that covet kind of
disrupts that a bit because you can't
i wasn't able to see any people as much
last year but
still like having people within arm's
reach has been helpful
and being able to like you know eat with
people in restaurants readily with a
within with
like a 30 minute uber ride
i'll just add something just i guess
just to put things into perspective
it is obviously more challenging to get
a job in the us as an international
like there's no getting by that it is
true but i guess it's just a comparison
of
you know would it be easier if you
hadn't gone to an mba and hadn't come to
the gsb i would say it's definitely
much advantageous to i guess apply while
you're
in school as an mba candidate and so
it's all about perspective and
i guess if you are committed to staying
in the us
um you could certainly prioritize
employers or types of jobs that
give you sponsorship or pursue an
entrepreneurship journey that could give
you that status and so
it's about your own priorities and so
nothing is guaranteed but there is
certainly a higher chance of you staying
if you choose to pursue that path
and if you want to come back i'm sure
you know i guess that's another question
that i can address which is
uh well kind of um because i'm not an
alumni yet um
we speak about how the alumni pool of
the gsb might be smaller in some
countries and i think that's probably
true
um but i think it also speaks to the the
depth and the strength of the network
because as we've already touched upon
everyone in the network seems to be
super super eager to help out and so
i think it's a it's a double-edged coin
kind of but
um it certainly has a advantage
advantageous
aspects
thank you both for those insights and i
see in the chat will is
also pointing to the bechdel
international center which i don't think
we've talked about yet so i am curious
about some of your experiences working
with the
bechdel international center and how it
supported your transition
from asia to stanford um as is the title
of this event so
any experiences with bechdel or examples
of
of the support and resources they
provide
i think like it they're definitely like
super supportive when it comes to visa
stuff that's all i can say
like anything you you can ask them any
question
about you know the legal the legal
things about staying in the u.s and they
proactively answer
um and you know they
you can walk there and actually ask them
in person pre-pandemic
and they're generally reliable and they
were like just a great resource for me
as someone who was trying to navigate
the
us immigration system as an
international
awesome thank you so i know we were
coming up on time
um i want to take one last question
perhaps in a lightning round
if you all are willing to to to do that
um so ramen dev asks how do students
spend their free time
and how does the gsb encourage long-term
relationships between
students which i love that question um
so perhaps in a lightning round if you
could say like what was one of your
favorite things to do
on or around campus or like what was one
way that
what was one of your favorite ways to
connect with other people
in our community
okay i can take a step first so uh the
first thing what was one of my most
interesting things that i did out of uh
listening um
was listening to my classmates talk so
talk is typically
a setup where you know one student goes
up and
tells their life story so that was that
was one of
the highlights um and the second uh you
know what other events were sort of
interesting i loved having
small good small group dinners with
smaller groups and sort of
get to know people on a more intimate
scale uh an intimate level
uh so that was my networking
method
awesome thank you i used to
uh hang out on town square
every thursday evening with a few
friends
uh and the group started snowballing
uh in the end i think we had a lot more
people than the initial like three or
four
we would get some uh mini wine
from koopa cafe and watch the sun set
that was my weekly pleasure and
something we
still do over zoom if it works out
and stanford has a beautiful golf course
um the course is great but the driving
range is beautiful too
sometimes we would stop by koopa and get
the same mini wine
and go to the driving range and
we would practice and we would call it
drink and drive
i'm getting sad but yeah those are
beautiful memories that i
that keep me keep me going when uh yeah
things are hard
thank you for sharing that
mine was simple just go out take a walk
with your classmate
and just get to know them where else
where else would you have
time to just meet someone with no agenda
no nothing's rushing you i think that's
a perfect place to do it
just to like you know be human
and be vulnerable so i think it's
fantastic to do that
yeah i also echo leo and i was just
points um one of my favorite things this
past quarter was taking the bike out
because schwab and jmac lets you rent
out bikes for free
and biking to the tennis courts and the
golf bridge just i would go to tennis
and call for the fight back
with friends um and so that was amazing
um and i don't know our free time we
don't really have a lot of free time
because our time is filled
up with talking to people doing things
just hanging out like you have time
blocks we're hanging out at manzanita
field which is a new field that we have
next to schwab and so
it's always a busy time but it's a great
time
um real quick lightning answer
plus one on rich for walks um one of my
best friends at the gsp
i literally went on to walk with every
single week for two years
and we still do a call every two weeks
um and so that just shows you like the
the level
the real the deep relationship level
that you can form with someone
and then um yeah and then and then you
can literally
the nice thing about the gsp is they
give you budget to do any event you want
and so i held a bunch of like filipino
food dinner
events um i held board great
board game and ice cream night and then
anyone could just sign up and that was a
great way to meet people
and also try the best ice cream in the
bay area
for free i mean i guess you paid for it
through your tuition but
technically but yeah you get it back in
a way
awesome thank you all so much for
sharing those really heartfelt stories
um i loved hearing them and i'm sure our
attendees did too
so thank you so much to all of our
panelists for spending this
hour with us thank you to our
participants for submitting your really
thoughtful questions
please let us know in the poll when
you're thinking of joining us and i'll
just throw up
one last slide the journey continues
at mystanford.mba thank you again to
everybody who's participated in this
event
um thank you so much for spending this
hour with us we hope you've gotten your
questions answered and
again another big shout out to our
panelists we're so grateful
um to be in community with you all and
to have this opportunity to hear your
stories
so thank you all so much and have a
great rest of your your day or your
evening
take care everyone
you